how much of the harm
that we are seeing from covet 19 if we
tomorrow were to address
um
vitamin d deficiency and we were to get
as serious as possible about alerting
people to the problem alerting people to
their special vulnerabilities if they
have dark skin or they spend a lot of
time indoors whatever their
vulnerabilities may be
and we were to start distributing
vitamin d with the kind of
aggressiveness that we are currently
pushing vaccines
how much of the harm of covid19
could be reduced well that's the first
because i've given this a lot of thought
and even written articles about it and
the answer is all of it
so even
different
there have been lots of papers
estimating what percentage of deaths
could be prevented and they vary between
80 and 100 depending on
the approach used was a recent paper
that targeted 50 nanograms per
milliliter that suggested that if we
could get everybody to that level uh
we'd go down to zero deaths but i look
at it from a slightly different
perspective
as a physicist um particularly with an
understanding of exponential processes
and uh this is a double exponential
process uh in a pandemic because you've
got the exponential process of viral
replication within the body and then
you've got the exponential process of
the sort of macro level of spreading
through the community and in any
exponential process if you can
add a prophylactic that lowers the
transmission rate so those are
effectively which everybody's now
familiar with which is nice if you can
push r below zero
uh which is pretty easy to do even if
you reduce our um by a small amount it
has a very big impact in terms of the
end number uh when you're dealing with
exponential processes
and
the effect of vitamin d is so strong
that you would wipe out the
pandemic if everybody was sufficient
because there wouldn't be enough people
it's a bit like if you have excuse me
take a drink of water to explain a bit
if you have
a dry fire
linda and i like to talk about trying
but embers and tinder um
exactly it's a very good analogy if
you've got a fire or rather a fire
that's about to be made of dry
tinderblocks that are all stacked
together
and you've got different strategies you
can use to stop that from catching fire
one is to move all the rocks apart
social distancing
or you can spray the wood uh to keep it
damp and then the fire doesn't catch and
vitamin d is basically like just keeping
the wood damp so that the fire doesn't
catch so even if it's a bit burning
somewhere if as long as you can get most
people to
a healthy level of green where the wood
is green then the fire just goes out
naturally
so
i believe i understood your explanation
the following way
you have two exponential processes viral
replication inside the body which is
going to be a correlate of how sick you
get
and you've got the exponential process
involved in the spread
and the point is vitamin d works in both
ways it causes the spread to be greatly
reduced and it causes the degree of
sickness to be reduced in individuals
and the combination of both of these
reductions
is enough to bring
uh are sufficiently below one that it
will eventually go extinct yeah and
that's what normally happens in seas in
in summer the effects the combined
effects of uv destroying viruses in in
the air plus the
improved host response drives are well
below
uh that value and then it dies out until
winter starts and then there's always a
pool of
uh viruses somewhere because you know
it's it's zoonotic and it's it's in
different animals and we don't know
really which species it crosses because
the studies that look at zoonotic
transmission are based on lab animals
and they've their host response is
completely different to wild animals or
animals in a food market in china you
know you just you really need to look at
different populations to understand that
well that's a very terrifying scenario
that you paint um you know well it's
also why the vaccine program is
dangerous and and and you know i'm not
you know lyndon both pro vaccines in
general as iu
we've taken every vaccine under the sun
and will continue to do so as long as we
believe in vaccines against
diseases most people have never heard of
just vaccinated a few weeks ago but the
reason the program for zoonotic disease
is like or any respiratory disease which
easily transmits between species
the human population represents 10
of the total reservoir because it's in
wild animals it's in food markets and
chickens and
pigs you have swine flu we've had bird
flu
um and you can't you're not going to
immunize all of those
animals as well so i've heard doctors
arguing that we need to get to 90
because that means that it's totally
controlled but if you then
you know multiply with that by 0.1
because we're only 10 of the total
population you see the fallacy of of
that argument we're never going to wipe
it out that way the only way we're going
to get rid of it is if we get our
um
our host response healthy and the way to
do that is through
good nutrition lifestyle
and not you know not depending on
solutions that are expensive that don't
really work or that have a limited life
because evolution is very clever at
getting around
whatever technology we create to stop it
well again i i think this is a very
terrifying scenario i mean if you were
let's say in the pharmaceutical industry
and you were depending on this new
market to continue to allow you to i
don't know uh
pay the mortgage on your new boat or
whatever it is that's driving this but
um
but yes for the rest of us
it's a very delightful prospect that we
actually might have the tools at our
disposal to at least drive this down to
a level where it is um
extremely well managed the way we could
say of something like plague or rabies
in the first world where
we never encounter these things
but driving it extinct would be uh
even more delightful so
we have coronaviruses all the time and
most of them are completely innocuous
people get them and don't even realize
this one obviously everybody is is
treating as if it's something that's
always fatal and that just isn't the
case of course it kills
people with comorbidities very easily
and we believe that's because they're
bitten indeed deficient it's not the
only reason i i think of it as the the
sort of um the breastplate of immunity
you know you can have other chinks in
your armor that go missing for whatever
reason but if the breastplate's missing
you're wide open you know it's just like
just get that in place make sure that's
protected
and you'll probably be okay
now this virus is not going to go
extinct and this is one of the
frustrating things that i've seen with
the public health response is that they
keep on promising the public if you do
this if you do that if you do that
covenanting will go away as if
the fact that we are more virtuous as a
society somehow influences what this
virus is going to do the virus does not
care about whether or not you care about
your neighbors or not the the virus just
does what viruses do and this particular
virus has been found in many animals
including wild animals
anytime as soon as you discover
that a
virus is also has a animal reservoir you
know it will never be extinct small
epoxy had no animal reservoir and that
is why we could drive it to be extinct
so so toledo has no animal reservoir
yellow people have reservoir it will
never be
so i i wanna i wanna ask you about this
because i've been tracking this uh
pretty carefully and i'm very cautious
about saying we can't drive it extinct
because although that is quite possible
i don't know of the piece of evidence
that tells us that now it sounds to me
like you're
drawing a very clear line at if animal
reservoir then extinction is impossible
but
um the animal reservoir you must be
pointing to is
white-tailed deer
no there are that that's the problem is
there are multiple wild animals
now hold on
you may
you may be telling me something i don't
know but
uh as far as i understand it we have
seen this virus uh move between
minks and ferrets
but these are domestic populations
there's a single case as far as i know
of a mink that has shown that it has
contracted
uh sars kovi ii but it was a mink in
close proximity to a domestic population
um there are many
because in utah they have mixed to
multiple
no you may be telling me something
that's more up to date than i know right
are you telling
more than one
yes and once you get it into a wild
population
it can go anywhere
and you cannot possibly immunize wild
every wild animal and also we haven't
tested all the animals there are too
many to test so we only have a very
limited view of what's actually
happening in the real world right my
point would be we don't need to drive it
extinct we need to make sure that it's
not a threat and it can be if it can be
shrunk down into something that's no
longer scary and terrifying and doesn't
make people ill and doesn't do the
rounds every year which is absolutely
possible um then
uh we won't need to worry about it sure
i i agree with this completely i mean at
the level that we've got plague
controlled uh i think we could all
breathe for example we deal with
influenza every year and i think people
probably don't realize we've been
vaccinating against influenza since 1945
to what end i don't that hasn't made a
single dent in what happens uh globally
it's just made a lot of money for people
who make those vaccines and the vaccines
are
frequently just part of why i was so
skeptical about these vaccines is
it's famous in
uh medical circles that the vaccine
efficacy that's touted by the trials
that are run um usually 1995 and some
years the actual real world efficacy is
as low as three percent
and it can vary by geography
um so if you if you don't need those
vaccines and instead you can help people
by
making sure their immune system just
worked properly in the first place that
obviously is going to take a lot of a
huge industry out
and i think that's why we're seeing some
nefarious behavior trying to suppress
vitamin d messages and and those those
actions have been going on for a very
long time i've i came into this uh march
2020 but i'm in touch with linda with
people who've been campaigning for more
than a decade and failing to get the
message
uh through for some reason and there's a
lot of
assumptions in that community that it's
because if people really knew the
vitamin d worked then many medicines
would suddenly be under threat because
it it affects so many different diseases
it's not just covariates cancers it's
you know all sorts of
autoimmune diseases psoriasis
name a disease it's probably something
to do with vitamin d
[Music]
you